last time we told you about a series of
blog post apparently written by MSNBC
weekend anchor joy read more than a
decade ago at the time read was not the
humorless progressive robot you know so
well today at the time her views an
immigration for example or somewhere to
the right of Donald Trump and that makes
sense since mass immigration hurts for
people the most well today we have a new
set of antique joy read blog post
uncovered by BuzzFeed in one post
entitled Baghdad John strikes again we
shared an image of John McCain's face
superimposed onto the body of the
Virginia Tech master couldn't do that
today we'd also promoted a 911
conspiracy documentary she attacked
congressman Barney Frank of
Massachusetts for the crime of being gay
and she wrote a satirical piece about
tony blair son visiting gay bath houses
in the u.s. spicy read of course
previously claimed that her blog had
somehow been retro actively hacked by
unseen saboteurs probably Russian agents
or Macedonians or something that's
almost certainly alive but it was
definitely amusing how will she explain
these well we're still awaiting a new
excuse from NBC News as soon as they
make one up of course we'll be the first
to tell you